[Musique]
en excellence est un jour de travail
comme les autres on est en semaine on
est dans l'usiné et je travaillais qu'un
collègue et et je suis distrait de
nature j'ai mis la main dans la machine
quoi c'est une presse plieuse et la
machine s'est en remis le pied sur la
[__]
donc il y avait ma maman dedans et ça
lui a sectionné j'ai tout de suite
compris que c'était terminé
[Musique]
dès que j'ai vu la première image de
cette prothèse qu'on me proposait je dis
tu te réticents savais pas du tout la
forme d'une main ce qui est moche moche
on aura une demande playmobil en fait le
sentiment de colère il peut dérailler
toute une vie et de tristesse il peut
durer toute la vie est la seule personne
qui peut changer ça c'est moi quoi c'est
la personne concernée quoi qu'ils disent
en fait faut que j'accepte que je dirais
pas que je suis pas faire les choses
comme avant en tant que j'accepterai pas
je serai dans la colère
[Musique]
oui la détruit
service
bah
[Musique]
à
pourtant
et là on le truc est complètement
renversées c'est bien c'est le truc
qu'on regarde le plus donc c'était le
truc que je voulais et ne plus cacher et
d'un seul coup c'est c'est ce qui attire
le plus
[Musique]
à
ça bouffe et entretiennent tu peux
choisir la couleur est là avec ça je
peux faire je veux pas trop le faire
certains c'est plus solide avec sa g
free s'est mêlé à la 1000 euros là
[Musique]
c'est super ça vite fait en deux jours
ces couillons pour tester voir le
en fait il n'y qu il a accroché aux
vivants donc s'ils se casse la gueule en
vélo il reste accroché au guidon
alors que ça en fait ça permet de
décrocher quand même ouf
tu te diras j'aimerais bien faire ça
ouais ok je te fais pour être la
prochaine
ben ah bon
[Musique]
je me souviens première fois que j'ai
environt babille
j'ai envie de mourir bah oui mélange
[__] c'est vrai mais n'ont même plus
jamais c'est juste comme tout c'est
juste que tu as un autre style c'est
pour ça que l'handicap des fois tu as
hatten en fait tu dis tiens je peux plus
faire ça mais en fait ça c'était ce que
je voulais faire c'est ce que j'avais
peur de faire maintenant que je suis
devenu handicapé et que c'est trop tard
mais en fait pourquoi ne pas essayer
puisque finalement c'est trop tard donc
je vais tout donner pour je vais je vais
le faire quoi et puis
jusqu'à ce qui est génial est-ce que
jusqu'à ce que j'y arrive c'est ça que
ça apporte des fois le handicap en fait
sa porte le fait que tu t'accroches
[Musique]